HBO's Game of Thrones came to an end in the
spring of 2019. Even its biggest fans have
to admit that many story arcs simply don't
add up. These are some of the most puzzling
questions Game of Thrones left in its wake.
Spoilers for the entire series to follow!
As Game of Thrones begins, King Robert Baratheon
is on the throne of Westeros . Right away,
viewers learn about his famous conquest of
the Seven Kingdoms with Ned Stark by his side.
After overthrowing the raving King Aerys Targaryen
, Robert became fiercely protective of his throne,
seeking to kill any young Targaryen threats.
"I’ll kill every Targaryen I get my hands on!"
In the aftermath of Robert's
death, his illegitimate successor,
Joffrey Baratheon takes that
mission several steps forward,
ordering the systematic killing of Robert's many
bastard children to ensure his own status as king.
Unfortunately for Joffrey, he misses one important
bastard: Gendry , a gifted young blacksmith.
Gendry goes on to survive the entire series, but
his Baratheon blood never proves to be climactic.
Just before the end of the show, Daenerys
Targaryen legitimizes him, making him
Lord Gendry, despite the fact that doing socould challenge her own claim to the Iron Throne.
One of the most famously infuriating
moments in Thrones' final season is
Daenerys' lightning-fast decision to slaughterthousands of innocents in King's Landing.
As Daenerys and her team prepare to attack King'sLanding and Queen Cersei Lannister , Cersei's
brother and Daenerys' right-hand man Tyrion tellsthe Targaryen heir that when she hears the bells
ring in Westeros' capital city, she must backoff. As he explains, the bells mean surrender.
"If the city surrenders, they will
ring the bells and raise the gates.
Please, if you hear them ringing
the bells, call off the attack."
This would be all well and good, except thatduring another crucial battle set at King's
Landing, Varys tells Tyrion that the bellsring for "horror," typically related to war.
Daenerys begins the show as the
khaleesi of a wild Dothraki horde.
After losing and gaining control of
these proud horse lords many times over,
she eventually makes her way to Westeroswith a massive Dothraki army at her back.
After losing one of her dragons to the NightKing, Daenerys finds herself at a disadvantage
as the White Walkers head towards Westeros.As the battle begins, seemingly most, ifnot all of her Dothraki warriors charge,
and areimmediately snuffed out by the army of the dead. However, just a few episodes later,after Daenerys overtakes King's Landing,
the camera pans across what looks
like thousands of Dothraki warriors,
enthralled by her speechabout conquering the world.
David Benioff himself said that the Battle ofWinterfell was quote, "essentially the end of
the Dothraki," so how does Daenerys have somany horse lords left after that frigid battle?
In the series finale, Tyrion
is given free reign to choose
the next monarch. He decides
that Bran Stark, who has quote,
"the best story," should be crowned Branthe Broken, and rule the Seven Kingdoms.
Whether or not Bran actually does
have "the best story," this choice
makes little sense. Bran has become theinhuman and omniscient Three-Eyed Raven:
As he has made clear, he cares
about little, including the throne.
After Game of Thrones spent years
signaling that a great leader would
be honorable as well as cunning, why
does his sister Sansa , who is both,
get a junior queenship while
her brother gets the real prize?
Game of Thrones' biggest mystery
always concerned the White Walkers,
an undead race of beings who live
in the far north beyond the Wall.
The White Walkers and their leader, the NightKing, pose an enormous threat to all of Westeros,
as the army of the dead will eventually makeits way to the Seven Kingdoms and wage war.
Throughout the series, viewers get smallpieces of information about the Walkers,
including that they are given
babies as offerings from humans
who live north of the Wall, who
they turn into tiny Walkers.
However, in the season eight episode "The LongNight," when the Walkers finally make their
way to Winterfell, Arya Stark dispatchesthe Night King without too much trouble,
and the mysteries surrounding the WhiteWalkers die with him and his entire army.
In the seventh season, several of Daenerys'allies go on an ill-advised mission north
of the Wall to try and prove to Cersei that theWhite Walkers are real. Southerners like Cersei
consider them to be a myth. Thus, Tyrion proposes
capturing a wight and bringing it to show Cersei.
However, this plan is foolish right from
the start. Wights rarely travel alone,
so trying to capture a single wight and return
it in one piece is essentially a suicide mission.
Also, Cersei is certainly shocked
by the wight when she sees it,
but she wages war against them anyway,and all that Daenerys' suicide squad
has to show for their trouble is
a stray wight and a felled dragon.
After Daenerys swoops in to rescue
the gang, she suffers a major loss
when the Night King shoots one of her
dragons, Viserion, out of the sky.
The image of Viserion's eye
reopening with its new blue hue is
definitely one of Thrones' coolest
visuals, but the mechanics of how
the Night King and his army retrieve the dragon
from underneath the ice raises some questions.
Earlier in that same episode, the wight-capturers
keep Walkers at bay by isolating themselves on a
rock surrounded by water, as wights can't swim.
If that's so, how did they retrieve Viserion?
Beyond that, the army of the dead uses enormous
chains to drag Viserion to the surface:
Where did they get those, and how did
they attach them to the dragon underwater?
On 'Game of Thrones', one of the most
difficult obstacles is travel. For that reason,
early seasons of Game of Thrones are
more or less devoted to long journeys,
making it clear that people like Daenerys, who is
trying to get to Westeros, have a long way to go.
However, as the show continued, writers
focused less on Westeros' sprawling landscape,
to the point where the rules of time and
space seemed to stop mattering entirely.
Journeys that would have once
taken a season and a half
eventually only take a couple of minutes.
Gendry can run from a mountaintop north of
the Wall to send a raven to Daenerys, who
arrives on a dragon shortly thereafter.
Suspension of disbelief is fine for a
show that involves dragons and magic,
but Game of Thrones' space-time continuum develops
not just a tear, but some pretty enormous holes.
Melisandre is a cryptic priestess of R'hllor , the
Lord of Light. Initially, Melisandre, who serves
Stannis Baratheon until his death, is the only red
priest viewers meet, but others eventually appear.
Beyond their fire-related powers, they deliver
prophecies, especially Melisandre, who makes
sweeping proclamations about
chosen ones and rightful kings.
"Stannis Baratheon, warrior of
light, your sword awaits you."
These prophecies are all exciting in the
beginning, but by the time Game of Thrones draws
to a close, none of them have been fulfilled. When
all is said and done, Melisandre's predictions
have little to no bearing on anything in the
show's outcome and are never explained at all.
Bronn is a fan-favorite as the
beloved, wise-cracking mercenary
who spends time with both Jaime and
Tyrion Lannister throughout the series.
But a bizarre plotline takes
place during the eighth season,
in which Bronn agrees to kill Jaime and Tyrion
simply because Cersei offered him money.
He threatens the brothers with a crossbow, then
isn't seen again until the finale. By then,
Tyrion has made him Lord of Highgarden,
which he promised Bronn in exchange for
his and Jaime's lives, as well
as Master of Coin to King Bran.
Earlier in the series, Bronn says he's never
borrowed money and doesn't know how it works,
so making a man who can't figure out the concept
of a loan the Master of Coin seems unwise.
Game of Thrones is home to plenty of
moments that require viewers to put
aside some of their logic and reason,
especially when it comes to injuries.
After characters like Khal Drogo die
of afflictions like blood poisoning,
you’d think that a serious injury might
take a character down once in a while.
Both Jaime and Arya endure brutal stab wounds to
the stomach during fights: Arya loses a tussle
with the Waif in season six, while Jaime struggles
against Euron Greyjoy in the final season.
And yet, neither person seems much
troubled by these grievous injuries.
Jaime makes it into the Red Keep to find
Cersei, while Arya somehow leaps into a canal,
swims across Braavos, and is eventually cured
by a cup of soup and a good night's sleep.
Armor can be effective against
knives, but apparently,
being a series regular can save you
from multiple stomach wounds as well.
Beyond her unhelpful prophecies, Melisandre
does a fair amount of magic on Game of Thrones,
much of which concerns blood sacrifices.
To help Stannis gain the throne,
she sacrifices his followers
and countrymen to the flame.
She steals "king's blood" from Gendry for a
ritual that will destroy any usurpers to the Iron
Throne. She even convinces Stannis to burn his
own daughter, Shireen alive, to win the War
of the Five Kings. Shireen dies screaming, her
mother hangs herself, and Stannis loses anyway.
With all that in mind, many viewers
were terrified of who or what Melisandre
would sacrifice after she revived a
murdered Jon Snow. This time, however,
Melisandre doesn't have to sacrifice anyone
— she just brings Jon back from the dead.
If she's capable of resurrection
with nothing but her own power,
why did she have to kill all those other people?
After Daenerys’ husband Drogo sustains
an infected wound, the dragon queen
can't keep her husband from a grisly
death. Bereaved but newly self-confident,
Daenerys sets her sight on Westeros,
putting her romantic life on the backburner.
Though Daenerys takes a few lovers,
she never truly falls in love again.
Until Jon Snow arrives, and the two
fall head over heels for each other.
Putting their lackluster chemistry aside —
as well as the fact that they're actually
aunt and nephew — Daenerys risking her
quest for the Iron Throne over a lover
is wildly inconsistent with her character.
It doesn't make sense, until you consider
that, as a plot device, it forces Jon to
face some internal conflict about killing the
woman who'snot just his queen, but his lover.
Samwell Tarly might be one of Game of Thrones'
most lovable characters, but he's definitely not
the toughest fighter. While out in the far North
with a few other men from the Night's Watch,
Sam and his black-clad brothers
hear a horn sound three times,
indicating that White Walkers have been spotted.
While Sam's compatriots make a run for it,
he can't catch up, and so he hides behind a rock.
This leads to a thrilling scene in which Sam
watches an entire army of Walkers make their way
towards the Wall, but it also raises questions.
Not only would he not be able to get ahead of
the army, but a Walker atop an undead horse
makes prolonged eye contact with him.
The White Walkers will kill anything in
their path. Besides the fact that he's a
main character, why is Sam any different?
When audiences first meet Jon Snow and Ned Stark,
they're told that Jon is Ned's shameful bastard,
the product of an affair with a tavern wench.
But Ned prizes his honor above all else,
making the situation seem a little shady.
Ultimately, the truth is revealed; Jon isn't a
bastard at all, but is the legitimate product of
Ned's sister Lyanna Stark and Daenerys' brother
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen, who married in secret.
As Lyanna lay dying with Robert
Baratheon's forces approaching,
she begged her brother to keep Jon's real
identity a secret, to save him from Robert's
sword. This is true enough — but the lengths to
which Ned goes to keep this secret are extreme.
For years, Ned's loving wife Catelyn
resents Jon as shameful proof of her
husband's infidelity. Couldn't Ned
have told his wife the real story?
Jon Snow has one of the toughest
journeys on Game of Thrones, yet somehow,
he ends up with a reasonably happy ending.
After helping Daenerys conquer King's Landing,
he realizes that his queen and lover
has turned evil in her quest for power.
In the aftermath of her massacre of King's
Landing's civilians, he stabs her for the
good of the realm. Though Daenerys' loyal
soldiers are furious, a deal is reached,
and Jon is banished back to the Night's
Watch, landing him right back where he began.
Jon is always happiest when he's north of
the Wall, so at face value, this seems like
a perfect ending. However, there's a catch: The
Night's Watch no longer has any reason to exist.
The Night's Watchmen protected the Wall
and the realm from White Walkers, but
without them, there's nothing
for the Night's Watch to do.
It's a neat ending to send Jon
back to his brothers in black,
but it also makes absolutely no sense.
Pretty much everything that Euron
Greyjoy does in the final two seasons
of Game of Thrones makes no sense. As
Thrones' final conflict draws near,
Euron's niece and nephew, Yara
and Theon , steal his best ships.
Euron manages to build 1,000 ships
in pretty quick order and from there,
he gains perfect aim overnight, taking down one
of Daenerys' typically impervious dragons with a
perfect shot — from a moving ship, no less.
He's at multiple major disadvantages, yet none
of them seem to actually matter. In a show that
prides itself on taking fantasy tropes seriously,
Euron Greyjoy stands out like a lucky sore thumb.
Out of all the characters on Game of Thrones,
Tywin Lannister is probably the smartest man in
all of Westeros. Tywin is a political master
who stops at nothing in his quest to elevate the
Lannisters. This makes one of his personal
relationships extraordinarily confusing.
During the show's second season, while Arya
is on the run from King's Landing in the
wake of her father's execution, she ends
up being Tywin's cupbearer at Harrenhal.
The two strike up a solid rapport, especially
when Tywin realizes that she's well-educated.
However, that fact alone should have revealed
Arya's identity. Tywin knows that one of the
two Stark girls has escaped, and Arya's knowledge
betrays her highborn status almost immediately.
Tywin may be the cleverest man
in Westeros, but apparently,
even his considerable brain has its limits.
It takes Daenerys until the start of
Thrones' seventh season to arrive in
Westeros. She makes a triumphant return
to Dragonstone, her ancestral home.
In a near-silent scene that closes
the seventh season's premiere,
Daenerys strides across a shore she barely
remembers. At last, she's finally ready to
take on her Westerosi foes. However, there's
one thing about this scene that doesn't add up.
After Stannis' death, why didn't anyone
acquainted with the Lannister forces even
bother trying to take Dragonstone? As a coastal
stronghold, it would have been wise for Daenerys'
enemies to send even just a few soldiers
to protect the place where she was born,
especially because they
likely knew she would return.
Cersei might be a vicious power player
throughout Thrones, but she does
truly love her children. Watching
her lose her two younger children
in incredibly tragic ways almost
makes you pity the villainess.
"She was good. From her first breath, she was
so sweet. I don’t know where she came from."
However, we know long before her last child
dies that losing children was her destiny.
In the fifth season's premiere, a young Cersei
meets a witch who tells her that she will have
three children, and that their crowns
and shrouds will both be golden.
Yet in the show's second episode, Cersei tells
Catelyn Stark that she once had a brown-haired
baby, presumably the baby she had with
Robert Baratheon. That would mean she
had four children, making this otherwise
correct prophecy suddenly null and void.
In the series' final episode, Bran is chosen
as the next King of the Seven Kingdoms, but
before anyone can celebrate, Sansa asks that the
North, which has always belonged to the Starks,
maintain its independence. Bran agrees,
and Sansa is crowned Queen in the North.
It's pretty strange that neither Yara Greyjoy,
who has been angling for the Iron Islands'
independence, nor the unnamed prince of Dorne,
a region with a long history of independence
from the other kingdoms, asks for the same thing.
Sansa gets what she wants — so why don't they ask
too, instead of accepting the fact that their
precious kingdoms remain under Bran's rule?
During Thrones' fifth and sixth seasons,
Arya undergoes a massive transformation
when she trains at the House of the Undying in
Braavos . It is here where she learns to be a
faceless assassin, and the mysterious girl
known as the Waif plays a huge role in it.
As the apparent right-hand woman to
Jaqen H'ghar, the Waif despises Arya,
beating her without mercy after Arya loses her
sight, and eventually trying to assassinate her.
Aside from setting up conflict for Arya,
however, there's not really much reason
for the Waif to exist, and her presence and
animosity towards Arya, go completely unexplained.
Once Arya leaves Braavos, we never see either
Jaqen or the Waif again, and it's even more
unclear as to why the Waif ever existed.
After learning to assume other people's faces
and kill her enemies in Braavos, Arya proves
herself to be a formidable assassin, taking down
her enemies as soon as she arrives in Westeros.
For years, however, one enemy looms above all
the rest: Cersei Lannister. It seems like a
foregone conclusion for much of the series
that Arya will be the one to kill Cersei.
However, Arya does not kill Cersei. Instead,
the Hound warns her that killing Cersei
will end up killing her as well, as the
Red Keep is on the verge of collapse.
Somehow, that one sentence works,
and Arya turns back, and Cersei's death
fails to bring Arya's story to a close.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more LOOPER videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.